hello rejects Greg here hey rejects
reality you do when the camera's not
rolling it's like an abusive
relationship and the camera's not
rolling I kind of like it I'm kind of
drawn to abusive relationship all right
so we're gonna watch the trailer for
majora's i'm at the trailer of the short
film that fan film majora's mask as i
say it was in Mijares majora's mask
terrible not majora hold on no I'm
confused I don't know why I got confused
I was thinking of one time I went to a
restaurant and someone was like I like
your phone case because my phone case of
Zelda and he's like ah
did you like Majora's Mask and I was
like what what did you just call it the
stuff is remembering not but it's
Majora's Mask yeah this from the channel
ember lab and this video is doing really
well right now
Breanna white is a Zelda fan and this is
this deals with Zelda right yes because
I remember the one after Oh Korean times
Majora's Mask yes it's crazy that every
every four or five years we get this
rumor that they're gonna make a
live-action Zelda film and they never do
it's never gonna happen in fact on April
first a few years back when one video
game movie finally gets it right we're
gonna get a [ __ ] ton about the Uncharted
movie does well more assassin's creed's
going or Assassin's Creed but Uncharted
is just better for movies a better
translation to movies I think totally
I'm waiting for that well let's see what
this is all about see if we can test
your Zelda knowledge maybe my notice
Easter eggs I don't know what this is
all gonna consist of I've never seen
this so I'm very excited
a few good things I can still feel its
power that sound yeah
Franzen means it
dog
Wow that looks pretty real is that not
real whoa
it's crazy I don't like like a little
meatball
does this guy letterbox
that supposed to be Mario yeah the
little of Nintendo Easter egg that's in
the game too
who's this dude that's the the mask man
mask seller yes
creepy
this is feeling very Lord of the Rings
right now one ring
Oh what the hell's going on
whoa
so that is isn't it over do you be more
it is over whoa whoa a lot more that was
like that was like Jim Carrey's the mask
at the end when Jim Carrey puts on the
mask and he starts to transform that's
what I thought fling stuff to me explain
stuff to me so the whole plot of
Majora's Mask is that the moon is
falling from the sky to destroy the town
and it's all because of Skull Kid with
this mask possessed him and so he's
bringing down the moon link has to save
the town by stopping the moon from
falling down but you only have three
days and so you have to use the song of
time to go back in time every time you
run out of three days time Oh
interesting yeah it's really a very
convoluted complicated story but it's
way darker and more sinister than
Ocarina of Time its predecessor so this
was like a short fan film dedicated to
like the origin of that villain it's
better yeah it's been a really long time
since I've played Majora's Mask so I
might be wrong
but if I'm remembering correctly this
doesn't actually happen in Majora's Mask
you don't actually get to see this
happening so this is sort of a
reimagining the mask seller says it was
stolen but they never show how it was
stopped so this is showing that yes
showing that you remember when there was
a little carving on the tree so in the
original game you can go you find the
carving
the tree and you click on it and that
triggers the backstory where you see
Skull Kid with the fairies tatl and tael
you know dancing around the forest
before I became possessed by this mask
that part was in the game and I loved
how they tied that in there because you
have to tie some familiar elements in
there so that you can lock into the
nostalgia really yeah which is why when
you see Skull Kid floating at the end
like it is all chill pose but like in
the air very sinister like that is
nostalgia that is like true to the game
and so sinister and so dark yet also so
casual I felt so much nostalgia such a
good so much choice you know like from
Link to the Past when I last played this
game or a little bit of ocarina actually
no I beat ocarina of time good for you
yep I've kept up to date all the games I
wonder what they plan to do with this
like if they're trying to plan something
more if it's just a tribute video
because that was really well done the
animation is incredible was a huge huge
huge kudos I think when they were in the
forest I thought it was real it does
look real and you know sometimes with
with CG these days they do actually take
you know real video footage and then
integrate the CG on top of it okay and
so that's how they can make some parts
look really real and that's easy to do
especially with landscape so that might
have been a technique they used yeah
that's really easy to do I do it all the
time none of this is yeah we're not
sitting on anything no oh my gosh just
done so well and you know when I first
saw the the mask man and how his
animation was done I was like you know I
liked it for a fan film but I don't
think I would want to see a full Zelda
movie done this way but by the end of it
I was like sold if that could make it
financially viable while giving it the
story and the attention that it deserves
I would be okay with that well I thought
it would be cool if this was like the
opening to a movie oh right there's like
the opening there where I when it cuts
the black then you cut to wherever link
is at the time and then you could get
your movie like actually going oh I saw
that kind of like a prologue to them oh
yeah yeah when do they want to get like
a funding for something
I feel that when Nintendo games those
are the ones that if you're gonna make
feature-length I feel like those are the
ones you can keep like CG animated I
agree I thought it'd be cool if they do
like if they created their own like film
universe out of it oh yeah and they
totally could
yeah bring them all together for the
Super Smash Brothers movie or something
like that with a Mario Party movie
Nintendo is notoriously closed off with
their stuff yeah don't like to share
rights with anybody so if Nintendo was
gonna be doing anything Nintendo would
have to become a movie studio I just
feel like after they did Super Mario
Brothers the 90s movie that you're just
like lost complete faith in the idea of
doing movies and you know there was a TV
series Zelda yeah they were donkey you
want to me princess just know it a Mario
one and a Donkey Kong one two I think
those I think the Mario one was live but
the other ones were like animation yeah
Donkey Kong what I remember being
animated that still feels like it could
be epic and Khalid it's great but that's
why with these video game movies they
have to have fans of the movie making it
because you have to have that healthy
dose of nostalgia and the things that
people love about the game but also sort
of like hate about the game like that
soundbite that they put in of the
Clocktower going for air and like every
Zelda fan is like what time is it you
know like you have to have those moments
I feel like every video game movie needs
those things and that's why I'm so
concerned about the Uncharted movie
right I have the exact same concerns we
identify so much yeah cuz I have a
gaming channel and I totally understand
why well guys this is kind of the real
rejects but more importantly make sure
to subscribe to Breanna why it's gaming
channel no it's more important strange
rebel gaming go check out her channel
she does a lot of Let's Plays on there
it's a really fun fun channel what are
some of the games you've done let's
place up well for those of you
lovers I can let you know that when I
was at e3 I got to spend a bunch of time
demoing breath of the wild so you should
definitely go check out my predictions
reviews for that that's not out yet no
it's been it's been speculated that it
will come out in March but then it was
said that there was a lot of like
substantial rumors that it wasn't going
to be a launch title for the switch and
so then we were thinking okay maybe
welcome out in March and it's all just
speculation at this point but please
give me this game early early enough I'm
done waiting please I heard a few beg
enough you usually give you one that's
what I hear
that's why I hear that's why I always
just beg for anything I want that's how
we got the new president shameless
beggar Wow camera cuts now